yeah thank you very much for me there
was a competition so this is gold for me
and I think all of your films are
amazing so wow I wrote a speech but i'm
just gonna freestyle this so i hope i'm
not gonna forget anyone I thank the
Academy as you said I'm amazed I'm to
meet audio feed filmmakers and also do
other filmmakers in this room you all an
inspiration and I want to thank my crew
my cast everyone who was supporting us
in the film I cruise over there I want
to thank me shot my producer and was so
strong to as an Indian come to Bavaria
and manage to produce the film almost by
himself I want to thank my co-producer
assignment was for being so strong and
being on the set and basically helping
us out so much I want to thank Justin my
do p for being a really good friend and
basically for I could trust you all the
time you met all those amazing images so
thank you he's mine so don't try to
touch it I want to thank James my
wonderful editor for the long hours that
we spend together and for having really
good ideas and also found in really good
humor which I think you can see in the
film I want to thank my actor leave
eisinger who's came in tonight for
trusting in me from the beginning on I
also want to thank my casting director
Barbara Barr miser who believes in the
project from the beginning and also
pushed me to get the actors that I got I
will also want to thank my assistant
director who was a backbone of the film
koo senator and I want to thank the
northern film school our teachers lara
anderson dan wheldon and keith the end o
for giving us the freedom to Bruce us by
ourselves I want to thank Michael
Bentham the tutor helping me in the
script writing face and also teaching me
of chromatic comedic timing I want to
thank my girlfriend Vanina for her love
and for keeping me grounded I want to
thank my family and I want to thank my
parents for 44 ways supporting me and
giving me laugh and to to to follow my
heart and again I want to thank the
academy for knowledge and comedy as
out foam thank you very much